father's very very patriotic and my  father's very very conservative and my  father he does not take lightly to  people badmouthing the country because  you notice geraldo rivera [ __ ]  he's talking negative about the country  he goes but the good news is they left  an email address on the tv so i decided  to write geraldo rivera a letter he  always says his first name the whole  name  and he goes all right paul here you go  he goes  dear geraldo rivera  how dare you speak about the united  states of america like that your  treasonous [ __ ]  i can't believe they gave an ugly [ __ ]  like you a television show in the first  place with your stupid [ __ ] mustache  you don't deserve this country or to  make money in this country anyways go  [ __ ] yourself  wait's a beat and he goes paul be honest  what'd you think